Professor,
thank you very much for doing this.
We've we've never met. I don't know a
great deal about you, but I have seen a
number uh of your videos in which you
make remarkably accurate predictions.
Um, so that's what I know about you and
I'm impressed by that by your ability to
call events before they happen. So with
that in mind, let me ask you, where do
you think this war in Iran is going? How
will it be resolved? and what are the
consequences likely to be?
>> Well, thanks so much for inviting me,
Tucker. I'm a huge fan. I've been uh
among your work for a number of years
now.
>> Thank you.
>> So, I think that this war in Iran uh
will be very similar to the war in
Ukraine, meaning that this will be drawn
out, be a war of attrition. Uh neither
side will concede defeat even though it
is in their best interest to reach a
ceasefire. And this will have dram
dramatic consequences on the uh global
economy. Um and this war could drag on
for years and years. Already we're
seeing major repercussions on the global
economy in that flights are being
cancelled. Uh in Southeast Asia they ran
out of fuel. So they're asking people to
stay at home and um in a few more months
uh experts are predicting a food
shortage meaning that nations will be
forced into food rationing and um today
there's a major escalation in that the
Israelis struck the largest gas field in
Iran and Iran retaliated by attacking
energy infrastructure of the GCC. Um and
Iran has stated that its purpose, its
goal, its strategy is to move oil to
$200 a barrel, which will have um a
really significant impact on the global
economy because the entire global
economy is based on access to cheap
energy. So unfortunately, I think that
we can expect this war to drag on for
years and years. Eventually, America
will send in ground troops. Uh
eventually the hormos will be contested.
Um eventually this will spread all
across the world. Eventually other
nations be drawn in. So Saudi Arabia uh
is thinking about declaring war on Iran
and Saudi Arabia has a neutral defense
pack with Pakistan. So Pakistan will be
drawn into this into this war. So um
things are sping out of control and um
just recently um Ali uh Larajini who is
the de facto head of the Iranian war
effort was assassinated and um he was a
pomatic um elder statesman in Iran who
who had the authority to negotiate a
ceasefire. Now that he's gone um there
really is no more offramp. So um both
sides are committed to a long war of
attrition and uh the consequences for
the entire global economy are quite
dire.
That is u I I wouldn't say that's the
worst case scenario. The worst case
scenario would include a nuclear strike
by one or more actors and the
destruction of the Oxamos complex in
Jerusalem which would spark a religious
war. So that's as bad as it could get.
But you've just described
one step before the worst which is
protracted,
destructive, impossible to stop. So my
question is because there are so many
global players, big global players, the
US and China I think who would be hurt
by this, why is there not an incentive
to get it settled quickly and why can't
that happen?
>> Right. Um so once this war starts
it um it's it it achieves a momentum and
a logic of its own. So um the United
States h doesn't really have an offramp
meaning that if it um tries to negotiate
a ceasefire with Iran, Iran would ask
for reparations about $1 trillion
basically. um it would ask for the
United States to leave the Middle East
permanently to ensure its long-term
survival. If the United States were to
do that, then the GC the GCC nations
would collectively become client states
of Iran because only Iran can guarantee
their safety as well as um use of the
shared home. The GCC is the basis of the
petro dollar. So what the GCC does is it
sells oil in US dollars and then
recycles this money back into the
American economy. So if the GCC were to
abandon the petro dollar, then this
would have severe repercussions on the
American economy. Also, there'll be a
chain um a chain reaction in that um
Japan and South Korea would look at
what's happened in the Middle East and
decide that the United States can no
longer guarantee its their safety. So,
they would have to remilitarize
um and they would have spent all the
resources on on adapting to the possible
China threat. And then you have Europe
and the Europe um would look at what
happened in the GCC as well as in
Southeast Asia and they would be like
why are we fighting Russia? Wouldn't it
be in our best interest to negotiate a
peace treaty with Russia as soon as
possible? What this would mean the
collapse of the uh US dollar as a global
reserve currency. Remember that America
is sitting on $39 trillion in debt. And
so the American economy is a Ponzi
scheme that relies on um foreign nations
to continually buy US dollars. So the US
economy would not be able to withstand
essentially uh American withdrawal from
the Middle East. So the Americans are
stuck where they are right now
unfortunately.
>> What is the Chinese perspective on this?
I mean, it seems like China has an
interest in
peace in the in the Persian Gulf with
those seven oil producing countries. Why
wouldn't China step in and try to settle
this?
So, both United States and China benefit
from the status quo. Um, and China has
invested interest in seeing a very quick
solution to uh this war in Middle East.
China imports about 40% of its uh energy
needs from the GCC. So not just Iranian
oil but also Qatari natural gas. Right.
>> So as you point out, China very much
wants to see as soon as possible a
ceasefire. Um unfortunately um it is the
nature of the Chinese government not to
interfere in um foreign affairs. It it
China doesn't really have a geopolitical
framework, a grand strategy. it really
believes in global trade and it doesn't
really have a framework for how to uh
resolve armed conflict and so Chinese
policymakers are really stuck and in
fact Chinese Chinese policy makers have
come out publicly saying that they would
like uh the carnage the violence in
Middle East to stop as soon as possible
and for the straight moose to open up.
Um but unfortunately um as I pointed out
previously when war a war starts it
achieve a momentum and a logic of its
own and it's very hard to stop a war
once it starts.
>> So if your prediction is correct and I
pray that it's not and I'm sure you do
too. hope that you're wrong, but if
you're not wrong,
>> yes,
>> and this continues to grind in the way
that it is now, destroying energy
infrastructure, just really destroying
the civilizations uh of the region and
Iran and the GCC, what does that look
like in say 2 years globally? What's the
effect on the global economy?
>> Right. So, um this war it will
accelerate three major trends. Um and
nations will have to adapt to a new
reality in which energy is no longer
cheap and accessible. Uh the first major
trend is de-industrialization.
Um meaning that right now you just have
too many people living in in cities and
you can do that as long as you can
import cheap energy and cheap food. But
when cheap energy and cheap food are
gone, then you need people to work the
fields to grow food for your economy. So
you have to de-industrialize uh and
reduce your energy dependence. Okay,
that's one major trend that we should
see very soon. Second major trend we
should see is remil militarization in
that um before we had tax americana
where America basically guaranteed
global peace um and America basically
prevented nations from going to war
against each other. So for example um
Trump brokered a ceasefire between India
and Pakistan uh because these two
nations have much hostilities against uh
each other. But now that America doesn't
no longer has the aura of invincibility
and ability now that the American
military does does not come across as
almighty then uh America doesn't have
the power to stop kids from attacking
each other on the playground anymore. So
nations have to remilarize
um especially nations like Japan which
before relied too heavily on American
military protection. Okay. So that's
number two the remilitarization of the
world. And the third major trend we
should see is mercantalism. Meaning that
now that global trade is disrupted
nations, especially advanced industrial
nations such as Japan and Germany, they
need to create their own independent,
self-sufficient supply chains.
Fortunately, America doesn't have this
issue because the western hemisphere is
extremely wealthy uh and abundant in
natural resources. Um but if you are
Japan and Germany then you have to reach
out and expand your borders if you are
to maintain your industrial might. So
these are the three major trends we
should be seeing very quickly. Well,
here's something that thieves count on.
Security cameras usually stop where
Wi-Fi stops, right? Makes sense. So if
you got a barn, a job site, equipment
parked outside a long driveway,
criminals know there's a good chance
that nobody is watching this cuz there's
no Wi-Fi. And that's why we like Defend
by Tacticam. It's a new sponsor of this
show. Defense cameras don't run on
Wi-Fi. They run on cellular just like
your phones. They work everywhere. If
you've got cell signal, you've got
security. Middle of nowhere, edge of
your property, construction site,
wherever you need it. You don't need
Wi-Fi. It's big difference. And you can
see why it matters. So, we use these
cameras in places where Wi-Fi doesn't
reach. The setup is super simple. You
mount the camera, open the Defend app,
and you are live. You get clear footage,
night vision alert sent right to your
phone. It's great for construction
sites, ranches, farms, or anyone with a
property that stretches beyond a router.
And here's something we really
appreciate. Defend does not sell your
data. Not to tech companies, not to
advertisers, not to China, no one. Your
footage belongs to you. And that's big.
Plan start at about five bucks a month.
No contract. Cancel anytime. Visit
defendellcam.com.
Let's defend cellcam.com.
I mean, we've of course seen this exact
dynamic very famously in the last
century. And I do think Japan is the big
question mark because traditionally, you
know, a rising power, a great power like
China just kind of intuitively demands
hegemony in its own region. Like China
controls the east. I would imagine
that's the Chinese perspective. But in
the way of that are Japan, the historic
enemy, and South Korea, but particularly
Japan, and I know that people in your
country are very focused on Japan. So,
is it plausible that China allows Japan
to become say a nuclear armed power at
this point?
Right. So, um from the surface, it seems
as though Japan has a lot of structural
weaknesses. Okay? So, for example, it
has an aging population. It has the
oldest population in the world. That's a
huge constraint on the future growth
potential of Japan. Another problem for
Japan is that it is resource dependent.
It relies on imports for its resources.
Um and Taiwan clo it blocks off the sh
of Malaka, right? Because Japan requ um
um requires most of its energy from the
GCC through the sh of Malaka and Taiwan
will be a barrier. So if Taiwan were to
reunify with China, then basically Japan
could be blockaded and um they could be
starved. Um and the other major issue
with Japan is its economy where for the
past 30 years it's in a deflationary
spiral because of its um excessive debt
debt burden. So there are fundamental
weaknesses to Japan. But um I'm I'm a
historian and I study historical
patterns and what I've seen is that the
Japanese people are incredibly
resilient. You go back to the 13th
century when the Mongols emitted not
once but twice. And at this time Japan
was very much a feudal nation divided
into different thiefs and they came
together as a people to defeat the
greatest empire in in the world at that
time not once but twice. And you go to
the uh middle of the 19th century when
uh China was being carved up by these
western industrial powers and it seemed
as though Japan was what they be carved
up as well. But the Japanese engaged in
something called the Maji restoration
and in 20 to 30 years time they went
from a feudal backward nation into an
industrial power that ultimately
defeated Russia in the Russian Japanese
war of 1905.
>> Right? And then you go to World War II
when American devastated Japan uh not
just nuclear strikes but also the
firebombings. Yes. So at the end of
World War II, Japan was completely
devastated. But in like 20 years time,
in a generation, they became the world's
greatest manufacturing power. So I would
not count the Japanese out. There's
something about their culture that is
extremely resilient, um extremely
entrepreneurial, and I think that given
crisis, they will come together as a
people and adapt to these challenges.
Um, and so, um, I, if I were to bet if
if you give me like a billion dollars
and said, "In East Asia, you can invest
your money either in China or Japan, or
you could you could invest half and
half." Well, Tucker, I'll be honest with
you. Um, I would invest all my money in
Japan.
That's a what a fascinating analysis. I
I I agree with you. I just I mean
intuitively I agree with you, but I I
just wonder if China can tolerate that
given the history between the two
countries and the focus and just the
growth of China. Can they really allow
right in the middle of of East Asia a
competing power,
>> right? So the major issue with China is
that it sells itself the middle kingdom.
um you know jungo the middle kingdom
which is to say that the Chinese believe
that they are a universe onto themselves
what happens outside China doesn't
really impact China so it's important is
to maintain the national sovereignty of
China because it is a self-sufficient
nation that has no interest in the
outside world Japan is complete opposite
in that it is an island and it requires
to uh it basically needs to extract
resources from other nations in order to
survive as a nation so these are two
very different mentalities where um
China is very much an agricultural
self-sufficient nation that is insular
and conservative and Japan is an
outward-looking
um uh seafaring nation.
>> Interesting. So you it it sounds like
they they can coexist or well you just
said it you're not betting against
Japan. What about South Korea which has
the one of the lowest if not the lowest
birth rate in the world in contrast to
North Korea um and has basically modeled
itself uh on the United States. I mean
down to the to the most basic level. The
US pulling back from East Asia is I mean
that's going to be a transformative
thing I would think for South Korea.
What happens?
>> Yeah, South Korea is in a very
precarious position um partly because of
North Korea. Um so once the United
States is forced to withdraw from
Southeast Asia then North Korea can take
the initiative. Now the problem with um
this conflict is that Seoul the largest
city in South Korea it's only 30 minutes
away from North Korean artillery. So in
like a whole day um North Korea could
flatten Soul
>> and so South Korea is in a very
precarious position. Also if you look at
the economy of soul of South Korea it's
a very oified very corrupt um system
where just a few companies um control
the entire economy and this is what's
led to um intense competition in South
Korea which has led to the the extremely
low birth rate in uh South Korea. So um
South Korea is in a very precarious uh
position. But what I will say about the
South Koreans is that they are fanatical
workers. They work really really hard
and they have a long memory of colonial
persecution um from both the Chinese and
the Japanese. And these are fiercely
independent people. So I I would not be
surprised if North Korea and South Korea
were to were to come to a compromise at
some point uh because both nations
aspire uh for national reunification and
because China Japan will be in conflict
with each other then the Korean people
could actually um navigate this conflict
to their benefit.
>> That's very smart. I I I sense you're
absolutely right about that. Let let me
just ask you about an observation you
made parathetically a second ago, which
is because
South Korea's economy is oified and
centralized, it's a monopoly economy,
its birth rate is low. What's the
connection between economic monopolies
and low birth rate? Yeah, great
question. So, when you have a monopoly,
what you do is you create a hierarchy,
right? because everyone's trying to get
into these companies because these
companies are the most prestigious in
South Korea and South Korea is very much
a confusion culture where face is
everything. So um the problem though is
how do you get into these companies?
It's a very uh prestigious position
where everyone's trying to get in,
right? And so you usually get in through
the um college entrance examination um
which allows you to get into prestigious
university, right? So um if you are a
South Korean couple, your strategy is
either not to have children because you
cannot afford to play this game because
you need to send your kid to cram
schools, get the best tutors, basically
focus all your resources on ensuring the
child does well on the college
examination so that he or she can get
into Samson. Um or you can choose to
have so you can choose not not to have
any children because it's too expensive
for you. But if you choose to have a
children, you can only choose have one
kid because it's much more strategic for
you to put all your resources into one
kid and spread it over three or four
kids. Um so so that that's why um an
economic monopoly would naturally lead
to a low birth rate. So what you're
saying is intense competitions for
resources, scarce resources
produces an incentive that
results in low birth rate.
>> Exactly. because everyone sees
themselves as competitors against each
other and you lose a sense of community,
right? Because you have a lot of
children um because you want to
contribute to the community and grow as
a nation. But when you see your neighbor
as your enemy, then um that reduced your
incentive to have children.
>> Interesting. So what will be the
economic effects on China and and also
on the on the rest of Asia and Southeast
Asia, you know, Philippines, Vietnam? Um
if this energy crunch continues in the
Middle East,
>> the reality is that uh this war in the
Middle East is having a severe impact
already on uh the entire Southeast Asian
economy. So uh India imports about 60%
of its oil from the GCC. Uh Pakistan
also imports a majority of its oil.
Japan imports about 75% of its oil from
uh the GCC. China imports about 40%.
Okay? So all these countries are being
impacted and already Thailand, Vietnam
are running out of fuel. Um and you you
go to the gas station, there's just no
more fuel for your for your motorbike
and now people are being forced to work
from from home. There's there's fuel
rationing. Um there's no jet fuel. So
this is impacting all of Southeast Asia.
So the question isn't like who will be
impacted because everyone's impacted.
The question is who will be most
resilient and the most willing to
innovate and adapt to this new reality?
because we're not talking about a
short-term war. We're talking about a
long-term changeable economy. And I
think that China will actually be um the
least resilient and the least ready to
adapt to this new reality because for
the past 30 40 years um China has has
gone on very wealthy um because of the
global economy where it imports cheap
energy and exports manufactured goods
and the entire Chinese economy is
currently based on this model. Now, for
the past 20 years, China has been moving
towards a consumer-based economy and
more of an innovation-based economy, AI.
But unfortunately, AI itself is
dependent on cheap energy. And Chinese
consumers are refusing to spend money
for a variety of reasons. Primarily
because they're not they are not that
optimistic about China's um um growth
for the in the future. So, uh Chinese
household savings is about 4%. And
unless the government is able to get
Chinese to spend more money, then it's
it'll be very hard for the Chinese
economy to move towards a consumer-based
economy. So, um all of Southeast Asia
will be impacted and I think China will
be impacted uh the most in the long
term, maybe not the short term because
China still has access to Iranian oil.
You know, Scott does announced today
that they will lift sanctions on Iranian
oil in order to make sure the global
economy is not too impacted by this war.
But in the long term um the Chinese
economy it is now much too um focused on
export um and manufacturing in order to
shift to a much more diversified
economy.
>> Right? People seem to be more inflamed
not just emotionally but physically and
more tired than ever. And food is part
of the reason. Bad food tastes good but
not good for you. For most of human
history, people ate actual food, stuff
that your body recognizes, but now you
eat a ton of chemicals. Paleo Valley is
the solution to this. Paleo Valley's
bone broth protein is made from, let's
see, 100% grass-fed and finished beef
bones. That's it. No fillers, no
additives, no weird industrial
byproducts. It's actual food turned into
something you can consume every day.
Most people use it the way we do. You
blend it into a smoothie or coffee. The
chocolate flavor is top tier. It
actually tastes awesome. They also have
vanilla and salted caramel. Plus, they
make a savory original turmeric ginger
and an unflavored version you stir into
soup, rice, or even just mix with hot
water and drink like bone broth. You
could do any of those things or all of
them. Americans use Paleo Valley to
support joints, digestion, recovery.
Paleo Valley verifies sourcing and tests
for pesticide and that does matter. or
you don't want to drink pesticides,
though you probably do inadvertently. If
you want to add something genuinely
useful to your diet, visit paleo
valley.com and use the code Tucker for
checkout. 20% off your first order if
you do that. That's paleo valley.com
code tucker for 20% off. So, it's it's
it's not just the west that is locked
into the current arrangement where we
consume the east produces.
It's the east. They're they're locked
into producing. So this is a massive
reorientation for everybody is I think
is what you're saying.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And I I would say look the
east is going to be much more impacted
than the west because at the end of the
day the western hemisphere America they
I mean the wealth in the western
hemisphere is just tremendous. I mean
the western hemisphere is
self-sufficient but that's not true for
Southeast Asia. Southeast Asia is very
dependent on uh energy from overseas.
>> How does this affect Africa?
Right. Um so with this war in uh Ukraine
and with this war in the GCC um experts
are saying that in the worst case
scenario you could have famine in Africa
because so much of um uh food and energy
um sustains the African um economy and
and so um yeah
>> um okay just moving west now. Um what
about the GCC?
What does that look like in 5 years?
>> Right. So unfortunately
the um biggest loser of this war
regardless of how how it turns out okay
even Americans were to win the biggest
loser is the GCC because for the past 30
40 years um the GC is basically b built
on a mirage because it's essentially a
desert with very little access to um
fresh water and very little agriculture
and so it couldn't really sustain a
large population. Um but with the petro
dollar and with American military
production then um the GCC nations felt
free to invest in technology that
allowed them to grow their population.
Right? So these desalination plants um
modern infrastructure. So you sort of
saw this massive growth in Dubai, in
Qatar um in Riyad. Um and what this war
has done is shattered this mirage and
revealed uh the limitations of the GCC.
So for example look at Dubai. So Dubai
for many years has prided itself as this
safe um very cosmopolitan very open tax
haven. So a lot of wealthy people
immigrated to uh Dubai but um because of
this war and we're only talking about
like a few drones hitting hotels um it's
really shattered the image of Dubai uh
and once you shadow this mirage you can
never ever um um rebuild it again. So
the idea of Dubai as as like the future
New York or London, the financial
capital of the GCC, it's this mirage has
evaporated.
>> Iran in 5 years.
>> So Iran is being devastated right now.
Um so the Israelis and Americans are
attacking um critical infrastructure. So
the Israelis uh attacked the largest gas
field in um Iran. The dissalination
plant uh was uh destroyed. But we also
have to remember what is being hidden
from us. And what's being hidden from us
is the fact that the Israelis and
Americans are trying to destroy the
capacity of the state to govern the
nation. Basically destroy the state's
monopoly on violence. And so what what
we're hearing are attacks on police
officers, on military installations, and
there's talk of special forces going
into um Iran and starting to fund fund
dissident groups, right, like the Kurds
and the um Galakis in souththeast
um Iran. So no matter what happens um in
this war, it's going to be very hard for
the government to maintain national um
control um even if they were to survive
this war. And also another huge issue
for Iran is that for the past few years
it suffered drought issues. Um so it
agriculture was heavily impacted. They
were actually talking about moving um
terrain uh um like moving these millions
of people out of the city of terrain
because the capital can no longer
sustain this large population. So um
this war will only exaggerate these
environmental issues um especially with
the attacks on critical civil
infrastructure for example dams
reservoirs um the dissolation plants and
it's going to take years and years for
Iran to recover from this war um as a
nation and you you have um basically the
storing of ethnic settlements um you
have the destruction of the state's
capacity to deliver basic services. But
the good news for Iran is that it seems
as though they will be able to maintain
control over the strip of hummus. And
that is critical because now they're
able to charge a toll on anyone who uses
a strip of homeus. And they're talking
about 10%. Which should generate about
about $800 billion a year annually for
Iran. So the nation will be destroyed um
in this war. But um it but if it's able
to harness the u pride of the Persian
people, if it's able to unify the
Persian people uh and it's it's able to
leverage the resource of the most um
effectively then uh we can expect uh
Iran to rise again in like 10 to 20
years time.
>> Where is Israel in a few years from now?
So if you look at the main beneficiary
of this war, it is Israel because Israel
has an ambition called the greater
Israel project which is what they
believe that their God Yahweh promised
to their um ancestor Abraham. Um and so
they believe that Yahweh promised uh
Abra Abraham all the land from the Nile
in Egypt to Euphrates in um Iraq. If you
look at the entire map, it also extends
to Anatolia, which is southern Turkey,
and even into Saudi Arabia. So, if you
look at what's happening, well, it's
convenient in that the GCC is being
destroyed. Saudi Arabia will probably
drawn into this war. It is possible
Turkey will be drawn into this war as as
well. And this war allows Israel to
remake the Middle East in its own image.
Also, if you think about it, according
to game theory, the main constraint to
Israel achieving the greater Israel
project is actually not Iran, but
America. Because America guarantees the
military safety and protection of the
GCC, uh Saudi Arabia, Qatar, Kuwait,
Ban, uh UAE, these nations. And so if
Israel is become dominant, uh it's
become the hedgeimon of the Middle East,
it needs to figure out how to remove
America from the equation. And quite
honestly, uh this war has shown the
limitations of American power. It's it's
really um annoyed the American people.
The American people do not want this
war. American people have don't even
understand why America is still in the
Middle East. And so it's very possible
that regardless of what happens in this
war, America's forced to withdraw from
the Middle East, in which case Israel is
able to achieve its greater Israel
project. Standard security cameras
cannot prevent breakins. They can help
catch burglars after they've done it.
But that's a little late. No. They can
steal your stuff, scare your family,
maybe hurt you. You need a security
system that will stop home invasions
before they occur. That's why we always
recommend Simply Safe. Simply Safe is a
whole home security system backed by
24/7 monitoring agents you can rely on
even when you're gone. Proactive crime
prevention. It's not reactive and that
makes the difference. Plus no required
long-term contract that gives you
flexibility to switch if you don't like
it. That's unlikely though because we
think Simply Safe is excellent. And
they're so confident in the protection,
they back it with an anti- theft
guarantee. Used by over 4 million
people, 20 years of experience. Named
best home security system of 2026. It's
the peak of the industry. And right now,
listeners to this show can get 50% off
their new Simplysafe system at
simplysafe.com/tucker.
That's simplysafe.com/tucker.
There is no safe like Simply Safe. It
was clear to me that that was part of
the motive um that Israel understood
this and
rope the United States into this war in
order to get the United States out in
order to hurt the United States and get
the United States out of the Middle
East. Do you think that will be
successful?
Um I think the way this war is going,
this plan will work. And the reason why
is the the American military has not
fought a real war for decades. 2003 this
war in Iraq was not a real war because
Saddam Hussein basically gave up. He
didn't have air defense because those
economic sanctions had destroyed his
economy. And his logic was this. Let the
Americans invade. They can't possibly
invade because if they destroy us that
would make Iran uh which has hostilities
against America the regional power. So
why would America do this? It is
self-defeating. It is not logical. It is
not rational. So I'm not worried about
them um um attacking me. And he was
surprised when they did attack because
it was not logical. It was not rational.
Um but they did they did attack. It was
it was a cakewalk. It took about two
weeks. um America achieve um air
supremacy very quickly and they rolled
into Baghdad in very very quickly and
toppled the regime. So that was a very
quick and easy war that fit the American
military of shock and awe. Um, Iran is
completely different and the American
military does not want to fight this war
because they've war game this countless
countless times and each war game they
discover that they they they lose
because the American military it's it's
too bulky. It's not as nimble and
resilient as the Iranian military. And
we're seeing that play out right now
where you have these devastating um
carriers, Abraham Lincoln and Nerald
Ford threatening uh Iran but not
actually doing anything because they're
afraid of getting too close to the coast
of Iran because then they they become
susceptible to drone strikes as well as
hypersonics. So the Iranians have have
been preparing this for 20 plus years.
They know the entire American playbook
and they have the perfect strategy to
counter uh the American playbook. So
America will have a really tough time
winning this war. The great problem okay
the big question now is will America
send in ground troops because once
America sends in ground troops then it
becomes pot committed. It's it's mission
creep some cost fallacy it like Vietnam
over. So right now there's talk of 200
Marines uh who've um um coming in from
Okinawa. They'll be in the Middle East
in about 7 days time. Um and the talk is
the rumor is and I don't know but the
rumor is the intention is for for them
to take Car Island which is the main oil
for Iran. So Iran uh exports 90% of its
oil from that facility the island. And
if the Marines were to take it, it would
be great optics. you know, Trump would
look good on TV. It it' be a great boost
for the for American morale. The problem
is that you can take it, but you can't
hold it because it's too close to
Iranian coast and Iranians can attack
with artillery, with drones, okay? Which
means that you now have to take take on
the coast. You have you have to occupy
the coast and create a foreign operating
base, but then you're exposed to the
Zagos mountains, right? Which means that
you're now forced to occupy the
mountains as well. So, it's mission
creep. It's exactly like Vietnam where
in 1965
um 3,000 Marines went into Dak Nan to to
um occupy an air base and like four or
five years later you have you have a
half a million troops, right? So it
started off as a very limited um
self-defined mission but then it just
balloons. Um so America could find
itself in the situation very quickly. If
you were the commander-in-chief of the
United States, what would you do at this
point as of today?
>> The commander-in-chief meaning Donald
Trump.
>> Yeah. You get to make the decision. What
What does America do next? If it's
acting in its own interest, if it's
trying to preserve its power and wealth
at this point, what does it do?
>> Well, first of all, I would acknowledge
that all these events are
interconnected, right? So the sugar war
with China, this war in Ukraine, this
war in the Middle East, it's all
interconnected because American empire
is um too overstretched and it has its
fingers on everything and so it allows
its enemies to provoke it into these um
never- ending wars. So what I would do
is basically sit down everyone okay
including Russia, China, Iran and say
it's time for a new world order where we
are partners in this relationship right
before America was a hedgeimon before
the US dollar was a world reserve
currency. Uh but now what we want to do
is open a dialogue where everyone is
respected where um America is no longer
the bully but a winning partner in
creating a new economic order that
benefits everyone and not just and not
just a few.
>> I I think that's the the wisest possible
advice and probably the only path that
preserves civilization.
Um, and but there the one country
standing in the way of that is Israel,
which is the only beneficiary of this
war as you just said. I think that's
true. Can you think of another
beneficiary other than Israel of this
war?
>> Well, Russia benefits, right? Because
Russia is trying to win this war in
Ukraine.
>> That's correct.
>> And um and America is forced to lift oil
sanctions. And so now Russia is now able
to take all these war profits, right?
And then help the Iranians, finance the
the Iranians in the struggle against the
Americans and Israelis. So, the Russians
also benefit tremendously from this war.
>> Yeah. But fair point,
Israel has to be constrained by the
United States in order to do what you
just recommended it do. Is that
possible? Does the American president
have the authority to control its client
state?
Um, so if you look at the domestic
situation in Israel,
um, Israel no longer behaves rationally.
it is sort of overtaken by
esquetological fever. Right? So if you
look at uh videos coming out of Israel,
there are rabbis going around saying
that this war in the Middle East even
though it's destroying Tel Aviv, um it's
good for us because this will lead to
the to the coming of our Messiah. Um so
they believe that it is when Israel is
under the most strain when Israel when
the very existence of Israel is
threatened then God will intervene
because the Jewish people will come
together as a nation again and commit
themselves renew their faith in God. And
once God sees the um blind trusting
after the faith of the Jewish people,
then he will save his people by sending
his Messiah who will then redeem the um
uh Jewish people. So another saying this
is secular temporal matters don't really
matter. This war in the Middle East not
an issue. What matters is divinity. What
matters is our relationship with God.
Yes. So what matters is faith. and
nuclear bombs go flying doesn't really
matter.
What it's what's what's so interesting
is that you know 25 years ago at 911
whatever you think of how that happened
and why there was I saw it personally
you know a political Islam there were
wahhabists there were a lot of Islamic
radicals around the world and for a
bunch of reasons over 25 years that
hasn't disappeared there still exist
Islamic radicals but it's not uh you
know an important political force
anymore at the same time as Islam in
general has become much more moderate
and the GCC is kind of the most obvious
example of this there has been a rise of
Jewish
Wahhabism and evangelical Christian
Wahhabism so to speak I mean you've seen
this esqueological extremism among some
American Protestants Christians and some
uh Israeli and American Jews what how
did that happen what is at
right. So first of all I I don't think
we can over ever overestimate the
influence of esquetology in American
politics. So I'll give an example where
about a quarter of Americans are evangel
evangelicals and and a lot of them are
Christian Zionist. Um, so they believe
that Israel is crucial, the lynch pin to
achieving God's plan of and the return
of of Jesus. And so a very prominent
figure that you probably know very well
is John who runs something called
the Christiansite for Israel. It's 7
million um u members and these are the
people who are financing a lot of the
conflict in uh the Middle East um in
Israel because they're the ones who are
funding Westbank settlements. And so
Christian Zionism, it is an extremely
powerful political force in um in
America. So um your question is how did
this happen? Um and yes, the the issue
the issue is that this is a plan um that
has been in motion for centuries and
it's a very complicated um um uh history
but it involves um uh different
religious groups among the Jews Frankis
Shabbat Lubovich which you've talked
about but also involves the Freemasons
the Knights Templars the Rosacruians it
involves the Jesuits so you have these
different um different secret societies
different religious organizations
working together through the centuries
to achieve this plan for the end of the
world which heralds the messianic age.
Okay. Okay. And there are different
components of this plan but but the
basic components are one is the um
creation of the state the nation state
of Israel which happened in 194848 and
then you you need to have um the
building of the third temple which
requires the destruction of the AXC
mosque which is actually um which could
happen during this war um given what
we've seen so far. So, the Israelis have
closed off the Alex mosque um as well as
other religious uh sites like the church
of holy uh separ um to tourists these
past few days. Um there's rumors that
for the past two years uh the Israelis
have been conducting these archeological
digs under the AIC mosque to uh
basically uh destroy the foundations of
the mosque so so that it they they can
conduct a control demolition of the
mosque and blame it on a missile strike
from the Iranians. And there's actually
talk um among the Israelis of using this
plan to ignite a war between the Arabs
and uh the the the Persians. So the Alex
mosy need each to be destroyed for the
third temple. They also talk about this
war of Gog and Magog uh between Israel
and the entire world. Um then the coming
of the Jewish Messiah um the creation of
the greater Israel project. The return
of all Jews from the diaspora. Um so so
there are different components to this
plan. If you just observe geopolitical
events, we're seeing these events
converge together to today. I mean all
these events are playing out. So it
seems as though there are these very
powerful shadow forces working behind
the scenes. We don't know who they are,
but it seems as though they're able to
control deal policy in a certain manner
as to fulfill um their uh esot esotical
script.
>> What what role do you think Donald Trump
plays in this?
Um, that's a really hard question to um,
answer. So, so let's look at different
possibilities. Okay, the first
possibility is that he's been employed
as an actor and he's just following a
script, but he doesn't really know where
this movie is going. He's just doing his
part, but he's been he's manipulated
behind the scenes by people around him.
And you know um when reporters asked him
like why is this war in Iran happening
he did say that his advisers which
includes civil cough Jared Kushner,
Peter Hexf, Marco Rubio told him that
the Iranians were so close to getting a
nuclear weapon and that the Iranians
were attacked first. And so I was
basically um misled. And I think I think
that's probably true in that uh Trump
surrounds himself with certain people
that have a certain political
esqueological agenda. Um so that's one
possibility that he's just he's just an
actor. Another possibility is that he
himself has a mezzanic calling. Okay.
And what I mean by that is if you go
back to 20 uh January 2021, he was
politically dead, right? because the
January 6 um riots happened. Uh he he
was impeached twice and then after he
left office there was lawfare conducted
against him and he went bankrupt. Um so
so it was it was as though the entire
world went against him but now he's
president of of the United States. And
so how how would he personally
understand this? I think a lot of it is
God has asked him to serve. There's a
call to serve and he has to fulfill a
mission. what this mission is. Okay,
what this mission is whether it's to
save Israel, whether it's to save
America, whether it's a part of a
grander scheme, only he in his heart
knows. And I think no one except him
knows. Okay, so I think that's another
uh possibility. And the third
possibility is that this is all Israel's
doing. Netanyahu is the one who's forced
him into um this sort of situation
because Israel is attacked first. And
Marco Rubio said this where you know
what we we we wanted these negotiations
but the Israelis were planning to to
attack. If they attack the Iranians
would be compelled to attack both the
Americans and the Israelis and we did
not want to put our soldiers in harm's
way so we attacked with the Israelis.
Okay. So it's possible this all Nanyahu
and all his machinations. Um another
fourth possibility is they have they
they have co-opted him like there's
blackmail on him. there's um and and he
has actually no choice but to do what he
says because um he's compromised in a
certain way and maybe his family is
under threat. So all four are
possibilities and quite honestly I have
no idea which possibility is the most
correct. Yeah. I don't I don't think I
don't think anybody does and I've really
tried to keep you know speculation to a
minimum. You always want to believe that
people's motives are transparent that
they state why they're doing what
they're doing. But of course, you can
never know what's inside a man, right?
Even in yourself, it's hard to know your
own motives very often. So, I think
that's a that's a wise take. Um, what
happens to North America, United States,
and I I do want to include Mexico and
Canada. We don't think a lot about those
countries, but they're both massive land
masses and they have big populations and
they're our neighbors. And so, if the
world is reorienting, I think you need
to think in terms of continents rather
than just nation states. What What does
that look like in three or four years?
>> Right. So um from a geopolitical
perspective, if America is forced to
retreat back into the Western
Hemisphere, it needs to worry about um
resources.
And so it is in the best interest of
America to eventually uh take over and
colonize both Canada and Mexico.
>> Yes.
>> Mexico for its labor supply, Canada for
um its resources. You know, Canada is
probably the wealthiest country in the
world.
>> I know. Um, and so from a geopol
geopolitical perspective, if the world
is retreating into self-sufficiency, if
there's mercantalism, if there's trade
barriers, the America has absolutely no
choice but to ensure its own um um
supply networks. And that that means
eventually taking over Greenland, um
Canada, Mexico, uh Latin America, Cuba,
Venezuela. Um, so America doesn't really
have much choice in this ma matter. At
the same time, what we're seeing is that
this war as well as other events are
causing political fissures in America,
especially between left and right. So
witness what happened in Minneapolis in
January, right? Um and so we can expect
that as this war continues and there's a
strong possibility that Donald Trump
will call a national draft in order to
uh ensure the manpower to fight this war
then you will have rioting in the
streets you have massive violence in
which case the national guard is
deployed there's a plan to deploy the
national guard to all ma major American
cities by April and so unfortunately
America u it's probably going to suffer
a long many years of sectarian violence
U not a full-fledged civil war, but um
maybe something along the lines of um
the troubles in Ireland. Um you know,
I'm I'm not sure if you've seen this
terrible movie called One Battle After
Another. Uh it's just a terrible movie,
by the way, but um you know, it it gives
you insight into what a civil war might
look like where you have these insurgent
groups fighting against the the the
state. Um, so yeah,
>> but you expect the United States to hang
together as a coherent nation state.
>> Listen, Tucker, the United States is the
greatest nation in the world. The people
are open, generous, entrepreneurial,
energetic. Uh, the resources of America
are infinite. America is a continental
fortress. So that uh it's protected by
two oceans. America doesn't have a peer
competitor in um in in North America and
South America. Um and so I mean America
regardless of what happens, America will
still come out doing pretty well just
because of the pure energy um and
creativity of of its people. What? So
you mentioned Canada. Most Americans are
don't even know the capital of Canada.
Canada does not appear on their radar
doesn't figure in their thoughts. But
you described it as probably quote
probably the richest country in the
world. I think that's objectively true.
And yet Canada is not a a rich country.
In fact, it's getting poorer. Its life
expectancy is is declining. Its GDP is
declining.
And that's on purpose. The the nation of
Canada has been suppressed on purpose.
Its population is being killed off by
the state um through its assisted
suicide program and its population is
changing through mass immigration
against the will of the population. So
that country is being held down on
purpose and my question is by whom and
why?
>> Sure. That's a great question and this
is something that I struggle with all
the time because I am a Canadian
citizen. Um I went to school there. Um
so um my answer is that Canada was never
really a nation state. It's more of a
glorified research sorry glorified
resource colony. Yes. for the British,
the city city of London and um the
reality is now that the British um are
under a lot of strain um the city of
London is under a lot of financial
pressure it sees place like Australia,
New Zealand and Canada and what do you
do um if you have financial issues where
you corporate you you do corporate
restructuring right you change the
middle management right and um
historically
um you You know the British got got
along very well with the Indian elite
right they went into India and stole
trillions of dollars from uh the Indians
and the elite the Indian elite were
perfectly happy to help them right so
why not use the same model for Australia
for Canada so you know there are
millions of Indians who immigrated to
Canada in the past 5 years and it's put
a lot of strain on the Canadian economy
because housing prices are you know um
have have exploded and so orary
Canadians can no longer afford to buy a
house and uh it's put this uh pressure
on the Canadian welfare welfare system
on the Canadian economy and you would
think that the proper strategy would
have a moratorum where they're like you
know what we've had too many immigrants
and we need to close the borders and
absorb these immigrants because we want
to ensure that these immigrants have
proper housing they have decent jobs
right you would think that that that'd
be the right strategy but instead Mark
Mark Carney goes to India
and says we want more Indians and also
we'll give you scholarships to come to
Canada to study for free. Meanwhile,
there are a lot of Canadians who are
homeless, uh, who are unemployed and who
cannot put food on the table, but hey,
we want more Indians. So, if it's not
corporate restructuring, if it's not
trying to acid strip Canada, I really
don't understand the strategy for this.
Well, I mean, it's a kind of genocide,
right, against Canadians, people whose
ancestors
built the country. But you wonder what
the purpose is like this is because it
is happening all over the West, all over
the English-sp speakaking world in the
white countries, and it's not an
accident. It's not organic. So, it's
it's a it's a big picture, you know,
that spans from Australia to Ottawa. And
what are we what is that? Do you know?
>> Right. So, let's look at Europe because
in 2014 um this was a major turning
point in Europe because you had these
tens of millions of refugees uh trying
to escape these wars in the Middle East
um you know created by America's wars in
the Middle East and they were trying to
reach Europe and at this point Europe um
had a choice. It could choose to close
its borders and maintain its cultural
identity or it could open the
floodgates. And Angela Merkel, the
chancellor of Germany, she she said
something really really um famous and
that which stuck in my mind which is we
can do this. We are Europeans. Somehow
we can take in these millions of
refugees and welcome welcome them to
into our societies and thrive as a
people. And the complete opposite has
happened. You've got millions of these
refugees who um fled into Europe, not
because of their choice, by the way, but
because their nations were devastated,
right? Libya, Syria, Afghanistan, Iraq
were all devastated, uh in in these wars
in against terror in the Middle East.
So, um they go and these are proud
Islamists. They they they love their
religion. They love their family. They
love the community. And so, they're not
going to absorb themselves and
assimilate themselves into Europe. And
and today, you know, you're looking at
population replacement in a lot of
cities. You go to certain places in
Britain and you might think you're in
Cairo or Baghdad. Um and and this has
caused tremendous conflict throughout
Europe. I would not be surprised in if
like 2 to four years time you have civil
war break out, insurgencies break out in
place like Britain and and and France.
So the question is why is this happening
throughout the world at the same time?
Exactly. Why is it that these different
nations whether they're European,
whether they're Canadian or Australian,
why are they adopting the same policies
not just in terms of co right but also
in terms of like immigration and so
that's the one of the great questions
that we have to ask about the world we
we live in today. It seems as though
it's almost a control demolition of
Western civilization, right? The the
Angosphere uh Western Europe. It seems
as though these nations are are being
destroyed purposely. For what end? I I
don't know. But I would just say there's
a certain pattern that is that that has
emerged and the result can only end up
in the control demolition of these
societies.
>> I don't think I don't I don't even think
that's up for debate. I mean, of course,
just look at the bottom line numbers,
you know, of course, the white
populations are being killed on purpose.
And the question is why? And I don't
have the faintest idea. And I know
there's a lot of speculation as to who's
doing it. I'll just say bluntly, I don't
know. I mean, I know who the instruments
are, of course, but Kier Starmer is not
in charge of Great Britain. Mcronone
isn't in charge of France. I'm not sure
how many leaders really do have control
of their countries. I don't know how
many countries actually have
sovereignty. I I really don't know the
answer,
>> but something is going on. Is there any
precedent for this in history? Have you
ever seen anything like this as a
historian?
>> Right. So, you look at what's happening
in Ukraine where the war is lost. It was
lost two years ago. The Ukrainians have
lost over a million fighting men. A lot
of their people have fled overseas. Um,
no matter what happens in this war,
Ukraine is finished as a nation state.
it is no longer viable as a nation
state. And rather than emit defeat and
come to a ceasefire with Putin, what the
Europeans are doing is they're saying
that we're going to draft our men and
have them fight in the trenches of
Ukraine, which would be suicide because
the Russians dominate the battlefield
with their drones and artillery and
trenches in Ukraine. So, so it's almost
like like a suicide mission. But not
only that, but the Germans have said
that, okay, we we can only um draft
German men, but not Islamic men because
we we we're afraid of their loyalty,
which means that you have a situation
where, you know, local men like British,
French, German men are being sent to die
in the trenches of Ukraine. and um you
know back at home you have these
immigrant population that have not
assimilated into your culture. Um so
it's a so it's a really weird
strategy. Um and I don't know who comes
up with these sort of w with this sort
of stuff. And look there's no historical
precedent for this. There just isn't. I
mean there's been um incidents of mass
immigration.
Um you go back you go go go go go go
back to the fall of the Roman Empire and
how these um you know hordes of
immigrants flooded the the the Romans
and um it's almost impossible to
assimilate so many people eventually
there's going there's going to be a
cultural takeover eventually with so
many people who are insistent on
maintaining their their cultural
identity eventually because because they
have more children than you eventually
they're going to overwhelm your your
cultural identity.
Yeah. And I I do think that is the story
of history. One population replacing
another. There's no such thing as
multiculturalism. There's always a
dominant culture that, you know, that
insists on dominance, of course. I just
don't think
there's ever been anyone who thought
this could happen globally, like a
systematic targeting of a race for
elimination globally. I mean I well it
wasn't possible until pretty recently
but it would be interesting to know what
the plan is. There's clearly like a plan
behind that. There's a plan behind
everything. I I wonder how many
Americans do you think understand what's
actually happening in the world right
now?
>> You know, um unfortunately I think that
if you are educated in America, you
know, I I went to Yale Yale and so I I
know a lot of these Ivy League people.
Yes.
>> Um unfortunately we've been
indoctrinated to believe certain values
and these values are not questionable.
So, so for example, um there was a court
case that went to the Supreme Court
about affirmative action at the
University of Michigan. Um and
affirmative action is clearly against
American values, against the idea of
American meritocracy, right? But the
Supreme Supreme Court said that
affirmative action was good because
diversity is an inherent good. Okay? And
and it's interesting because if you go
go to a place like Yale or Harvard or
any of these Ivy League schools, there's
actually very little diversity. I'm
talking about intellectual diversity.
Yeah. I mean like there's different skin
color, but if you actually look at the
ideas
>> that they engage with in a classroom,
it's a very conformist setting. So it's
it's one of these great ironies where a
form of affirmative action is supposed
to bring diversity to the classroom. Uh
but if you go to any classroom in an
elite setting, it's extremely
conformist. you're not allowed to bring
up these issues about, you know,
population replacement, immigration,
because then you become you be called a
racist. Um because and that's the worst
thing to be called, right? It's I mean
like you're better off you're better off
being called a pedophile, right?
Pedophiles have more rights now than
than than racist. Um so um unfortunately
it's not just what's happening um in
current events. It's also what's
happening in the classroom where and in
in the c popular culture where people
are not even allowed to ask questions
that are like blindly obvious if just
walk the streets of any you know western
city. You've lived around the world. I
think you're now in China. Um
does the rest of the world see this more
clearly?
>> Yeah. I mean, if you're not in the west
and if you're not if you're not
subjected to this u brainwashing
indoctrination that they feed you uh in
in the schools, it's I mean it's obvious
again it's blinding obvious to anyone if
you just walk the streets of any major
city in the west. So there's a joke in
China and and so popular so Chinese
don't actually like to go to Canada for
tourism and um someone asked why don't
why does why doesn't anyone recommend
Chinese going to Canada and the response
was well would you recommend someone
going to India right so so it's a bit
racist I it's it's very racist okay but
I mean I mean you know it's obvious to
people
>> it's just interesting Because like I'm
not defending the whites. I am white of
course but you know white people have
done a lot of bad things just like any
people do a lot of bad things but in
general people like to go on as you just
noted vacation in white countries cuz
they're pretty nice. So I think you'd
have to say if you took the emotion out
of it and just like looked at it net net
whites have been you know pretty big
addition to the world invented a lot of
stuff created a lot of beauty created
places people like to go on vacation
which really is a good test. So like why
would you destroy all that?
Look, so in my school I teach the great
books. I teach western civilization. Uh
I teach Homer, the lead, the Odyssey. I
teach Plato, the Republic. I teach Dante
the Divine Comedy. I teach the Bible.
And my students love it. Uh because
Western civilization, it's it's just not
about people being white. It's really
about what it means to be human, right?
and what it means to be spiritual and to
have connections with with the divine.
So um it's unfortunate that um just when
the world needs western civilization the
most the west decides to destroy its own
civilization. I mean Homer, Dante,
Plato, Shakespeare, the Bible, these are
timeless classics that speak to every
human. I know because I teach in China
uh to Chinese students who have
absolutely no exposure to Western
culture yet they fall in love with
Plato, Dante, Homer and Shakespeare. And
why is that? And it it's because there
is eternal truth um embedded in their in
their words. And so um universities,
Western universities ought to be the
places, the fortresses that are the
greatest defenders of Western
civilization. But if you go again to
these elite universities, Yale, Harvard,
they are the most critical of Western
civilization. They don't they no longer
teach Homer and Dante Plato. And it's
like if you don't teach these classics,
what's the purpose of university? I
always I always thought the university
was the heart and center of
civilization, right? It it it it's like
what monasteries were in the med
medieval age. Um, and I thought these
professors, they they would dedicate
their lives to promoting the classics,
but instead they now promote complete
nonsense like DEI and um, yeah, of all
the and this is my last question,
professor. Thank you. It's been a
wonderful conversation and I hope it
won't be our last and I and I hope we
can have dinner when we're on the same
continent. Um, but this is my last
question. Where since you've traveled so
much and lived so many places and speak
multiple languages, where would you say
the part of the world that's most
hostile to Western civilization as you
just described it is? Trying to
understand where this hostility is
coming from.
Well, I would say
um Canada, Britain, Western Europe, I
would say these places are the most
hostile towards Western civilization. uh
Chinese people have tremendous respect
for western civilization uh in fact in
China's you know in the process of
promoting uh the classics uh Plato Homer
Shakespeare with in China because
Chinese recognize the tremendous
cultural value and immense eternal
truths embedded in these classics. So,
so we we're in a very weird situation
where um the West is destroying itself
by abandoning what makes it great. Uh-
which is, you know, these classics.
>> I think if we talk longer, I'm going to
start to cry on camera, so I'm going to
I'm going to take an emotional break
here. Uh, Professor, thank you.
>> Okay. No,
>> I do not mean
I'm half kidding. No, it's it's
emotionally resonant for me because I
know that you're telling the truth and
it comports with everything that I've
seen and so it's hard to accept
something that's true, but I think what
you're saying is true unfortunately. So,
uh, bless you for this and I hope to see
you again soon. Thank you.
>> Yeah, I really enjoyed it, Tucker.